welcome to this video game baccarat yeah
that's his real name i think probably
Bohar off yeah probably i'm kind of
screwing up the pronunciation but let's
see what we can do in this spanish this
ruler pass I'm going for the closed but
then I will vary not play my what she
going again yeah but I have not yet
studied some line in detail something to
do for for this year new year's
resolution yeah not really but I need to
do something they're not the passive
kind of play that I am that I did in
them in those old chegar in line this is
the smooth love variation with age 6
which is not a bad choice it's some in
some way comparable to the to the
zaitsev variation I cannot take to d4
and on e4 because of / 55 that's a it's
a funny funny tactic what i'm doing is
i'm preparing Knight a5 and then c5
again I think it's a good a good thing
to get the C porn involved if he closes
the center now which he certainly can do
it's not a bad idea I now can go g6
Bishop g7 always taking okay not bad so
that's an interesting way to play I'm a
bit surprised to be honest because it
looks a bit strange to combine night on
g3 with the tether capture on c5
normally you would try to play night III
putting it on d5 when you go for this
but I'm not saying that it is bad what
he played and just hit just a little bit
it feels some a bit uncommon to me
okay so what is he doing here Queen on
f3 if I go nite age 70 to see what this
is not doing on edge for sorry yeah this
was almost necessary right look T 1
maybe was a move but ok i'm just taking
this piece he just blundered this piece
to be to be perfectly frank let's see
but it's not so not so straightforward
he has a couple of pieces on my king so
have to be have to be a alert i wonder i
am something to e4 probably queen age
for a rookie force not something nice
and he might go to age five but i have
night f6 so maybe this bishop here check
King age eight does not look some
dangerous I'm not sure it so this is the
kind of position where you probably win
quite easily when you have time but in
blitz itself still came sooner bit
tricky it leaves at least if you are not
a super great tactician like I'm
definitely not not so great in
calculating at least when I have little
time on the clock and it gets
complicated yeah so what what can you do
when Queen h5 an idea of six looks
fairly safe I jack at least here it's
easy yeah I again I can go Knight f6 but
then while f7 hangs have seven hangs but
I don't know
f7 camp but he takes f7 let's not lies
he's really not coordinating really well
right probably go to each form and I
don't know taking it can take on f7 but
it looks fairly fairly safe to me the
Queen does not even have many squares
answer would be really nice if I can't
wrap his queen it's not so far off
actually if he takes f7 nice doorbell SI
quite a sound yeah yeah I thought I have
95 or moves like that just activating
shouldn't be too bad gaining this move
on the Queen and possibly night f4e our
night f4 is a move
yeah going there okay so night have a
night h5 or what exactly is the idea
maybe yeah this is this end route 8
looks fairly saver I mean here shouldn't
forget that I'm on g2 here right so be
sure one c6 rukon g8 that can easily
happen that I'm the one attacking and am
now threatening Knight f6 IAM trading
office is attacking peace okay well this
is this is this should be really good
for me f6 maybe something along these
lines it looks that almost looks like
the only only chance left hoping for
something with Queen f5 Queen h7 check
mail k is just going back
yeah I wonder if I should just play
neither for yeah this is the kind of
keep it simple approach opening up my
bishop and seeing that I get counter
play against g2 yeah and now I thought I
mean move the brush up simply all I mean
night c-4 would also Queen age 5 is a
move that I need to be aware of ok so i
do this i play a special g3 i mean i can
also move the bishop here look here
maybe one minute left
and probably returning returning one
pawn wasn't the best idea hi morning
it's really not that clear this position
and it is coming from a position where I
was really just winning so I probably
shouldn't have returned the material
check I need to get this night into the
game badly 9b 65 is what I'm trying to
get in okay let's see if I can take a
five I would be helpful
check this diagonal looks kind of scary
right how do I we now of this year check
just winning the rook probably it's the
easiest white reasons jam that was kinda
weird this is night each form which kind
of it left this piece totally stranded I
thought he could go look to you one
actually or queen yeah this this wasn't
necessary I giving up the piece I
thought rook to you one for a counter
pin but he I have that of course but the
compass just giving this funny movie
which is probably not bad just counted
jacking d7 and allowing the night to go
back so he didn't need to it didn't need
to sacrifice just yet but he did and I
mean it's not working definitely not but
it still is kind of kind of tricky yeah
I don't know about the most precise
defense but yeah maybe you should take
f7 here but I was thinking that I'm
winning tempe here with 90 f6 and maybe
I can get a rope to the to the G foul
yeah in here it's it's it's pretty much
over I thought that oops rook d 1 is
given by the compass unclear basically
Wow Rock d1
this is the idea going for a pin hmm
interesting
yeah and Queen h5 the combination of
both moves as a problem hmm interesting
means that Bishop g7 wasn't good it
looks totally normal compounds to play
see fire with with a plus to basically
the basically the peace and okay Eddie
I'm winning rod I'm winning again he
again here yeah this wasn't the best
probably but I just wanted to keep
things keep things simple okay the
computer is merciless wants to take him
yeah dyad typical typical computer stuff
yeah this is a win it seems not quite
sure yet why because I'm taking here
okay okay that looks good yeah I needed
to keep things somewhat simple with 40
seconds yep some it's pretty convincing
I think okay that was a pretty pretty
pretty good win he didn't need to give
up the piece so early so a bit strange
okay well thanks for watching